let's bring in Kevin Frazier the co-host
of Entertainment Tonight ke Frey is ya
hosting the Thanksgiving Day pro your K
phrase gonna do it again
I'm just watching last year with what
Kelsey Schulte I see healthy night
Keltie night Thank You Kathy night I
just want you last year yeah good I love
when you guys come out to the west coast
you know what's weird is I only see you
guys now like on red carpet or you know
stuff like that it's already events yeah
you've crossed over
you guys have crossed over it's very
interesting phenomenon I mean I'm just
saying I you know I crossed over so I'm
good to see that you got I'm glad to see
it you guys have crossed over yeah I
know
and I see you at the parties come on and
I've crossed you over before Dan listen
we go here every time you know dad's
never crossed me over
he's never we played one time again we
did play one time Dan one time I believe
because I was still like I was pre
Carmelo phase of my game I thought I I
thought I did alright I held my eye I
think somebody got some yeah but I give
some oh I get some all the time yeah you
can't stay in front of anybody but like
yeah yeah you hit a you hit a jumper and
I was like okay so now it's on and then
I was like whoa yeah oh but he can't
move here's no lateral movement yeah no
yeah yeah yeah just don't leave me open
I understand we didn't we was I'm like
the Warriors I'm gonna out score I'm
gone klay Thompson mmm let's say let's
say Carmelo at OKC okay I'll take that
okay that's legit well you're kind of a
black man Jim Legler a little bit yeah a
little bit better than legs
I mean legs never did he ever touch the
lame did he ever since our career
touched I love it I see Kevin out in the
halls and during the commercial break he
goes man I wish Josh Duhamel would still
been here man I'm ever playing against
him and I'm talking trash to him I said
why are you talking trash to Josh
Duhamel it was the craziest thing we're
in the entertainment league the NBA
Entertainment League and Fergie was
sitting in the stands they
even gotten married yet and I just I
looked up and I was like oh wow her keys
here and then I was checking Josh and I
was like yo you brought your girl to the
gym and then I hit a jumper then I was
like yo you better get your girl out
here you're about to get the business
and I just started losing my mind and at
first you know how it is when you play
basketball and then Josh looked at me at
first like I was crazy then he started
laughing cuz then he missed a jumper and
I was like your gate your jumpers
garbage yeah and I was saying it loud
enough so Fergie could hear me but the
best part was that I act and you acting
you act and he laughed and laughed and
laughed but then I went right from the
game to the Grammys on the red carpet
and Fergie the first thing she says when
the Black Eyed Peas walk up is like yo
that guy right there talks a lot of junk
and I was just like I was having an
out-of-body experience I was like losing
my mind and but josh is the best do you
do other people you play against who
else do you play against all I do is
talk now dad you all you know we hit a
point that's all I just talk I just walk
up and down and I talk a lot of walking
a lot of talking one little spurt you
know you have a spurt yeah and you're
like I gave you too big you can't even
check the young guys who come into my
house I always tell them I'm like I'm
older than your dad and I'm giving it to
you and I actually I play with a guy
named Steve Carlson who is the general
manager the NBC affiliate here now he is
over 60 in still plays three times a
week and so he's like my my basketball
sensei and we play together and it's a
mess what other actors do you play
against all the guys play in the NBA
eally I mean there was everybody was in
that same play too no it wasn't that you
know I acted we'll a little bit but I
mean we'll friend but I you know we'll
laughed what's who's first team All NBA
Entertainment link oh wow back in the
day I'm gonna go back in the day I'm
gonna back up Brian McKnight was really
good yeah and there were a couple other
guys you hadn't her Pookie Wigginton who
played for do you remember do you
remember Pookie no he was the point
guard when Tom Seton Hall lost to
Michigan he was the point guard and now
he runs all Kevin Hart stuff he murdered
in the entertainment league Kevin Hart
play basketball listen that's
entertainer basketball and let me just
say this when guys in and Hollywood
talked about they can play there's a
handful but most of them are just dudes
who like you and I can still get out and
run with Sandler can still play ok ask
Adam um when you're when you know we we
went one-on-one and I had on a full suit
I wore a full suit - um - when the movie
sets I'm not gonna say which one but um
and Adam and I play basketball on the
set we we went at it you know Adam can
tell you the story so you in a full suit
and shoes so you took him in a full suit
and shoes man
I like it but look I'm older listen I'm
letting those days ago I don't think so
Daniel gone no I don't think so
they never leave no it's hard man it's
hard I don't let it go but you know the
interesting thing about the
entertainment league was that there were
some crit like there were people who
took it so seriously yeah that they lost
their minds and there were guys who you
were just like yo you you you can't act
like that Rapoport was crazy every
single day Michael Rapaport kicked out
of every game he would lose his mind
cursing yelling screaming at the refs
and listen
Michael's a good guy but he has no game
but I mean if he goes to the hoop he
better get a foul and if he doesn't he
is screaming and cursing and losing his
my was crazy he's a good all day Kevin
Frazier Entertainment Tonight co-host
and he is hosting the Thanksgiving Day
Parade on CBS live from New York
fires affect you yeah well they didn't
affect me personally with my family but
we've been out there for the last three
days and uh it's tough to see the
devastation because we were with Robin
Thicke and you know when he went back to
his house and he lost everything the
first thing he said is like you expect
to go there and see just something a
picture a doll or something but the
fires were burning so hot they burned
everything down but I will say these
celebrities all of them that we have
dealt with the first thing they are
worried about is the first responders
you know the firemen their neighbors
they're going there to help they're like
we can rebuild we'll we'll be back but
we also want to help these other people
what can we do Lady Gaga going to the
shelters you know all these Chris Martin
um
so many people out there doing good
things and so uh hats off to all the
celebs who are helping and I saw reg
when I first flew in Reggie Miller with
his family said what we have is what we
have on our backs because they had to
evacuate and then his house is safe but
he showed me the video and I was telling
the dance you could see like it looked
like it was in black and white no it's
crazy because that's all you were seeing
and the fire went right up to his back
porch and the problem also is the smoke
damage so so many of these people if
your house didn't burn it's the smoke
damage and you go in and you're like
whoa they're gonna have to paint maybe
tear out some of these walls it listen
it is a national disaster and we have to
help all these people not only in
Southern California but also in Northern
California because when you fly we were
in a helicopter on Wednesday and we flew
over and it looks like the moon it's
just scorched earth as far as you can
see it will blow your mind and it's
gonna take a while to rebuild and help
these so we get we have to all chip in
and do what we can I know that the
entertainment value with the Lakers that
it's there's a referendum after every
game on this team it feels like yes and
and everybody is pleading to be patient
but then nobody is being patient here
all the first of all look at the team
the way it's constructed right now and
understand that it won't be that way
next year that agency and they're gonna
go big and whether it's chasing you know
whether it's chasing Anthony Davis
whoever they're going after someone and
they plan on getting someone so what is
happening right now is just it's this
year they're not gonna win a
championship this year
they're just relax everybody take a deep
breath but the thing is the cachet with
LeBron is what he came back here
everybody was so desperate and thirsty
for Showtime after two brutal years that
it was like oh we're back well it's
where the basketball is better now and
and by the way with LeBron I'm more in
to what he has done off the basketball
court to what he is doing on the
basketball court yes he may be the
greatest ever to play basketball but
also the things he's doing off the court
in the way he's changing the narrative
from his school to the kids he's sending
to school
I'm to college to what they're doing
with Spring Hill entertainment here in
Hollywood in the kind of programming
they're putting out it is phenomenal and
I can't say enough about that and I wish
more athletes would look at how they're
you know they will they need to start
they need to start know cuz there's some
dudes out there with a lot of money you
know who are just blowing it on t-shirts
and record labels you know and that that
needs that well I think that they're
gonna look at the blueprint of how to do
it you know Kobe is giving you a little
bit of a blue yes he has as well Jordan
of course gave you a blueprint yep but
but LeBron with that production company
and you I mean I talked to somebody who
met his son mm-hmm and said you know I
kind of went into it thinking that he
was gonna be you know the kid that dude
you know was stuck-up or full of himself
and said Bonnie his son brawny he
couldn't have been a nicer kid and I
said you know what you got to give his
what his wife his mom you know bronty's
mom a lot of credit with because she
stays in the shadow with look that's a
Savannah doesn't get enough credit for
how she is helped raise these kids but
also supported LeBron and he has done a
great job think about this he has been
at the top of the food chain for all
this time and he has stay out of trouble
he has been a great example and a great
leader for not only his team but his
community and that is something that you
gets I'm when you look at LeBron you
should look at him and say will there
ever be another athlete like that who
plays at that high level who can do so
much for so why is it that people don't
embrace him because people look at
basketball and here's what I will say
when it comes to community I look at
LeBron and I go back to the guys in 68
and Jim Brown and those guys and what
they were doing in their community
empowerment and that's why when I see
LeBron now I say oh that's a guy who got
it it's like he was he saw that
blueprint he was he knew those guys and
now he is taking that one step further
and I don't understand why people think
it's all about basket but they're
critical of him as a basketball player
it is what I say about people being
critical of LeBron number one is he the
best or at least the top three of all
time yes yes without a doubt okay are
you
about him moving around the teams okay
well if you had those same opportunities
in your job say you know you could move
in your job so tomorrow tomorrow you
know you know say tomorrow Jim Rome
calls you and offers you four times the
money
Fritzie what do you do what do you do
what's your answer sighs I stick with my
man tell you to go take that job first
he just goes I'm sure Dan would match
what he did say by the way Dan let's go
back to our ESPN days I mean we both
found better opportunities yeah and and
you know don't be I'm not mad at you and
I'm surely not mad at me
so if you have a better opportunity you
have an opportunity to do something
great what's wrong well we always say
when they took the like Durant took the
easy way out oh well that's that's that
but who wants the hard way
right but also look at look at what
Durant and people don't understand the
VC funds and the stuff that he's
involved with you know outside of
basketball step away from basketball for
a second and see how these guys are
using their money like Kevin's using it
in a really smart way he's made a movie
he's uh he's Kevin Frazier and I will
say you've got a nice jumper you do you
did what it's a nice nice jumper I will
tell you this damn what broke my heart
is I built a little you know quarter
court in my backyard because I was like
my boys are gonna come up there in a
play every day yeah this is gonna be
amazing I go outside and really I built
it for me I go outside that shoot my
boys have turned it into a soccer field
and it breaks my heart
they've got soccer nets up now and
everything and I'm it's devastation you
understand its devastation if you had to
put a week's pay on tiger versus Phil Oh
tiger it's not even I think Tiger will
light fill up I think Tigers would have
light fill up see I wish they would have
put up their own money I don't even care
because I think there's so much pride in
the things that go if we forget about
there was a few years where it was there
was some real animosity between us to
where it was like they were on the
course looking at each other like oh you
oh really oh you
you're a guy no I'm the guy in tiger I
love last night on TNT where he said
just look at my record score right well
you have a lot of seconds and thirds yes
it's good to see you safe travels to New
York we always love seeing you thank you
it is always great being here and seeing
the boys man he's a Kevin Frazier
Entertainment Tonight coast just tell
Nancy I said I will give Nancy a hug for
you and by the way next time I come I
gotta bring gear again cuz this is the
tragedy happening over here tragedy they
quit don't they quit on me it's like
they've been married like we've been
married so long anybody look decent over
there with the doughnut I mean know
unless you're I mean I'm going to a
school conference so I can be dressed
like this yeah I don't these guys are at
their job they're a national TV people
watch you every single day millions
listen to you and guys what's going on
what's happening they gave up you get
married too long yeah yeah Paulie
our job is always to make Dan look good
and I think we're doing it today did a
great job yeah I mean Fritz he's leading
the pack that's what I got to say oh my
god what you got him on Friday you know
after a week in LA yeah yeah so it's not
pretty
yeah not that it was better em on Monday
when we got here like these are the guys
who packing this time like a little bag
just a little tiny bag what's wrong with
that dog you have clothes you have
clothes like you have clothes in
different shoes you have like a pair of
pants anymore another pair of sneakers
besides those this week of course not
CBS live from New York we're back after
this on the Dan Patrick show for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
[Music]